hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's was türkisches und zwar
werde ich möchte machen also frikadellen
aber keine normalen frikadellen und zwar
ist das ein typisches ein rezept aus
zypern
na ja auf jeden fall auch türkische plus
kräfte oder passat es dürfte
denn in dem in den hackfleisch träger
denn ist noch ganz viel kartoffeln mit
drin also im prinzip überwiegend
eigentlich die kartoffeln und es sind
kartoffeln hackfleisch frikadellen ich
mache jetzt heute um reich später dazu
einen türkischen reiste habe ich euch ja
das rezept bereits hochgeladen da könnt
ihr gerne mal vorbeischauen und später
gibt's auch gemüse mit dazu ich denke
ich mache da tui gemüse dazu ich sage
jetzt erst mal die zutaten ich brauche
dafür ein kilo mehlig kochende
kartoffeln die habe ich jetzt bereits
geschält 250 km hackfleisch ich habe
jetzt fleisch vom rind eine zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe hier noch gewürze und zwar
einen teelöffel minze und einen halben
teelöffel kreuzkümmel 150 gramm
semmelbrösel 100 gramm gehackte
petersilie und salz und pfeffer die
petersilie ist übrigens von meinem
kräuter hochbeet und ich hab das gehackt
und eingefroren und jetzt einfach
aufgetaut und verbissener gefroren
nämlich die kartoffeln und die zwiebel
und die knoblauchzehe die werden jetzt
nämlich fein gerieben das geht entweder
mit der hand oder mit der maschine ich
mach das jetzt hier weil ich habe schon
einige kartoffeln
die kartoffeln gebe ich jetzt gemeinsam
mit den zwiebeln und der knoblauchzehe
in eine große schüssel ihr könnt es
jetzt alles mit der hand verkneten oder
auch mit der küchenmaschine was ich
jetzt gleich tun werde
da kommt das hackfleisch mit dazu also
man wirklich nur ganz wenig hackfleisch
und im türkischen sagt man dann auch
economy kräfte dazu und zwar es halt
günstig günstiger als wenn man das leben
nur mit hackfleisch machen würde jetzt
noch die kräuter mit rein semmelbrösel
und das dann auch die gehackte
petersilie bin jetzt nicht so viel
petersilie mitnehmen die sie nicht
komplett aber ich mag petersilie
wirklich sehr gerne in frikadellen
deswegen gebe es jetzt ganz mit rein und
jetzt kommt noch jeweils ein teelöffel
salz und pfeffer rein
jetzt werden die zutaten gut miteinander
vermischt
die masse fertig vermischt und so
sieht's aus sie ist auch sehr feucht
wenn ihr daran denkt ich habe es nicht
mehr dran gedacht könnt ihr die
kartoffeln wenn sie fertig geschrieben
sind auch noch etwas ausdrücken dass das
wasser raus geht aber falls ihr mal zu
feucht wird die masse dann könnt ihr
auch einfach nur bittlmayer semmelbrösel
mit rein geben sie einen esslöffel und
schlecht die masse ab und bevor ich
jetzt in die hand nehme habe ich hier
auch im schälchen mit wasser und öl
man könnte die händler mit einreiben und
dann klebt auch nicht nehmt ihr immer
die gleiche menge und formen zuerst
seiner kugel und dann etwas länglich
also der murat mag das auch ganz gerne
wenn die so ein bisschen länger sind als
und und dann setze ich sie auf einem
teller ab den könnt ihr vorher auch ein
bisschen einfetten
man klebt dann nämlich auch gleich
nichts dran
und jetzt vorm ich dir alle und schauen
sie dann danach aus wacken und ihr könnt
die so jetzt auch gut vorbereiten dann
noch einen teller legen den abdecken in
den kühlschrank stellen und dann erst
kurz vor dem verzehr durchbraten
die kräfte sind jetzt geformt und ich
habe jetzt einen teil hier einen teil
noch im kühlschrank jetzt nämlich etwas
sonnenblumenöl und gibt es in der pfanne
und ich werde es jetzt auch gleich in
zwei pfanne anbraten damit einfach ein
bisschen schneller geht
meine mama hat zum beispiel zu hause so
eine pizza pen also zum elektrischen
kind stieß mit der kanzlei am
netzstecker machen das so eine große
pfanne
man kann sie da direkt alle drin machen
vor allem kann man auf der terrasse
machen unterrichts daheim nach
gebratenem jedenfalls country pfanne
erhitzen und zwar mache ich das immer
ganz langsam an soll das jetzt nicht
sofort auf höchste stufe erhitzen
ich mache immer so mittel hoch es gebe
ich die kräfte in das heiße fett und da
nehme ich immer sonnenblumenöl weil es
geschmacksneutral ist werden sie darin
rundherum gebraten bis sie eine schöne
er ist eine goldbraune farbe haben
das sind sie auch in der mitte durch
hast du schon gesagt was fürs töten sie
heißt super viel sagen ich habe auch
schon erzählt economy kürze also günstig
könnt auch auf schwäbische genau
eigentlich schwäbischen frikadelle
findet wenig später will ich mal die
kombinierten sicher als hackfleisch
die ersten kräfte sind jetzt schon
fertig und murat du darfst direkt
probieren oder und ich warte jetzt
einfach noch weiter dass wir wollen also
ich habe als beilage türkischen reist
gemacht habe ich schon vorbereitet da
gibt es schon ein video von mir bekommst
du grad uhrig gemüse gibt es noch mit
dazu weil ich finde so fleisch reis und
dann noch gemüse
ja ich dir das so maria bietet mache ich
ja noch einen schönen teil
murat noch mal ganz schön hier der reis
es ist ja schön höflich ist fotos so
machst aber es ist auch schön ja ich
mache auch fertig kommt alles gut hätte
ich mich immer auf instagram vorne dann
könntest hierauf und her und schwarz
jetzt kriegst du noch zwei drei kräfte
mit dazu die gebe ich jetzt aus der
handtasche die probieren und ich kann
ihn derzeit noch ein paar wenden können
sie gar in harmonie zu beleben
ach so gut die köpfe kann schon mal mit
nennen lässt habe nicht schlecht
risen handy an ist mit euch
diese reicht ich bin mal gespannt was
für den crafter weil die schmecken hat
ganz anders als der reiseweg normale
hackfleisch verbinden sich gespannt
u
schmeckt ganz anders stellen ja muss
durch angewandt angeblich angebrachten
angebranntes mit kartoffeln die kosten
muss will stehe ich auch doch genau man
muss sie auch richtig langsam braten und
dafür wirklich ein bisschen länger da
werden sich schön knusprig das immer
schön auf mittlerer stufe zum ersten mal
und die sind halt innen außen knusprig
und innen richtig feucht also ganz
trocken new york komplett dicaprio ist
besser als eigentlich sogar komplett
vegan könnte man auch machen
so muss man dann wegen dem zusammenhalt
vielleicht gucken dass man bitte mehr
dazu gibt weil ansonsten die kartoffel
pur wird zwar aufhalten aber damit
verharre
wie soll das gerät auch schnell gemacht
oder ja nur das auspacken dauert ein
bisschen aber genau oder zu töten
das nur noch das trapattoni der reis und
das ganze richtig perfekt also falls ihr
dieses rezept nachmachen wolf von den
ganzen zyklus köpfte zur 1
dann könnt ihr gerne auf meinem blog
gehen verließ blog.de versteht noch mal
das rezept für euch und ich finde ganz
viel spaß danach machen und wir sehen
uns das nächste mal wieder biss dann die
assistenten und ich brauche jetzt
fertigen du kannst mal die tischdecke